hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear
and i'm finally getting around to
talking about this movie i have been
wanting to see this movie for a really
long time because i heard that it was
like really kind of messed up and
grotesque and you know i'm kind of all
about that uh so i noticed that hulu had
it so i was like okay well i really have
to push this up in the rotation because
i've been dying to see this movie
because i've been hearing a lot of
people talk about it and this movie is
the 2021 film titan which if you don't
know is the french word for titanium
and why it's called that will become
clear later on
i
loved this movie but i can see how maybe
some people i don't know i i kind of
feel like critically it was pretty
universally beloved and i can totally
see why but i kind of feel like
audiences will probably be like mixed on
it if you don't like really
bizarre grotesque
like body horror type stuff it's
cronenbergian a little bit um that's
pretty much like the closest thing i can
think to it but it's not exactly like
that which i'll get into in a little bit
so uh this is a french film as i uh
mentioned
and the uh director and screenwriter uh
julia ducornow i'm hopeful i'm
pronouncing that sort of correctly
she kind of came out uh back in 2006
she'd done some stuff before that but uh
back in 2016 she came out with this
excellent excellent movie called raw
which was kind of like a coming-of-age
story like about this girl who slowly
begins to
realize that she's really into
cannibalism and it's uh it's pretty
messed up and so that's really good too
if you haven't seen that so when i saw
that and i heard that this was going to
be her second one i was kind of like
whoo i was like really excited to see it
because raw was really good
so this movie comes out and i have to
say that as
kind of messed up as raw was this one
goes like way [ __ ] bigger bolder like
way over the [ __ ] top and it's pretty
uh amazing
as i said this is body horror film
pretty much uh it's also kind of a
serial killer movie and kind of like a
[ __ ] up family drama i know that
doesn't really make a lot of sense but
when you see it you'll you'll see what
i'm talking about now this movie
actually ended up uh winning her the
palm door at cannes and significantly
she's the only the second female
director to take the the top prize at
can which that is uh the first being
jane campion for the piano back in 1993
and i believe please correct me if i'm
wrong but i think jane campion shared
that with somebody else who was like a
co-directing credit so actually uh julia
um de cornell is the first woman to win
it like solo so it's kind of like a big
deal and it's amazing that it took until
2021 for that to happen but that's a
whole other discussion
now pretty much every review that i've
seen of this movie has compared it to
the david cronenberg film crash from
1996 which was based on the jg ballard
novel
and
i guess like superficially it does have
like a sort of i mean really the only
thing that's similar
is the sort of melding of
you know biological with
metal or with you know uh with inanimate
objects or with machinery
and the fact that the main character in
this has um an erotic attraction to cars
vehicles
other than that this doesn't really
follow the same story in any way because
i feel like crash you know whether the
david cronenberg film or the jg ballard
novel was kind of more about this
underground of people that got off on
car crashes essentially whereas this one
is kind of different to that yeah she's
sexually attracted to cars but a whole
bunch of other [ __ ] happens in this too
now i will say that if you want to watch
this movie it's on hulu and i'm sure
it's probably streaming elsewhere as
well it's better to go into this not
really knowing where he's going because
i guarantee like i was watching it all i
knew was like oh it's like a girl that
has a titanium plate in her head and
she's kind of sexually attracted to cars
oh like the david cronenberg movie and
that was literally all i knew about it
and it's better not knowing anything
about it because you will absolutely not
guess like the [ __ ] directions this
thing is going in i had no idea it was
like gonna happen next and that was like
really good so because i'm gonna spoil
some plot points i'm not gonna spoil the
end or anything like that but because to
talk about the movie i you know i've
mentioned this before you do kind of
have to spoil some plot points and i
think this is a better movie going into
it not really knowing much of anything
about it because it just has like all
these crazy like twists and turns that
are like really really surprising also i
will say too that
i think of the few negative reviews
mostly from audiences not so much from
critics because critics pretty much all
seem to love this
but i kind of feel like a lot of the
criticism was that it wasn't like
realistic or anything like that but i
don't really think even though it's shot
realistically i'm pretty sure this movie
is meant to be more like
metaphorical or like a fairy tale type
of thing it's not shot like in a
surrealist style or anything like that
but some of the stuff that happens in it
is obviously
magical realism is something that
wouldn't happen in real life so i just
kind of feel like you're supposed to see
it through like a metaphorical lens and
like maybe not try to take everything in
it so literally because obviously i'm
gonna say some stuff in there and you're
gonna be like well that can happen in
real life i'm like well yeah duh that's
kind of like the whole point of the
[ __ ] movie so there's there's that as
well
so uh what we have the main character of
this is played by a woman named agatha
russell now she's actually a model and a
journalist in france and this is
actually her first film role which is
amazing because she is
holy [ __ ] like what
what a [ __ ] brave performance this is
just in the sense that
the physicality behind it there's a lot
of nudity there's a lot of you know just
physical kind of like transformations
and it's like her having to like look
really [ __ ] up and ugly and all this
other kind of stuff and she really
[ __ ] sells it uh she's great in this
so it's amazing that this is like her
first film role she plays a character
named alexia
now this is a young woman who has some
uh kind of troubling proclivities let's
call it that
now there's kind of a prologue at the
beginning where they show her as a child
and she's in the backseat of her car and
her dad is driving
and she's really seems like deliberately
like getting on her dad's nerves like
going like making all like all these
like motor noises she's probably like
seven or eight i can't really tell
and he's just getting more and more
annoyed and like turning the radio up
and she seems like she's trying to like
get his goat on purpose um you know and
she and she seems like very calculated
you know what i mean like the her face
and [ __ ] like that
and uh again probably somewhat
deliberately she while he's driving and
getting all irritated she actually takes
off her seatbelt and like jumps across
the back seat at which case you know at
which point he turns around like being
like hey what are you doing kid and he
crashes the car now he's okay but she
busts her head against like the side
window in the back seat and
necessitating a titanium plate put into
her head
so then um it's pretty clear from the
beginning even before she gets in the
accident that she does kind of have i
mean just judging from the way that
she's making the car noises and
everything like that even before the
accident
she seems to have like an affinity with
machines rather than people because her
it's really weird like when they're
doing like in the hospital and they show
her like with the thing on her head like
in their you know with the scar and all
that and the fact that her parents just
seem very distant and she doesn't like
speak to them or she seems very very
cold
i took that and more like will come
along of that later i this is not stated
outright so i could be totally wrong
about this but i think that the
implication is
that
her uh dad is abusive possibly sexually
abusive like i said they don't come out
and say this but there's a couple things
in there that kind of lead me to believe
that that's the case and that that may
be that might be why alexia is so
emotionless is so cold and doesn't
really speak to her parents
so after she gets out of the hospital as
a kid she doesn't even talk to her mom
or her dad she just runs to their car in
the parking lot and starts like
caressing it in a sort of like sexual
way so like i said she has a very like
should be from a very young age she has
like an erotic attraction to cars
then we jump ahead several years so lexi
is probably like in her early 20s
now alexia is working as an exotic
dancer she still has the um the scar you
can see like there's and it's in the
poster if you see she has kind of like
this punky looking
hairdo and like this kind of weird kind
of like spiral sort of scar on the side
like because hair won't grow over it
that's where the titanium plate is so
she has that
and she's been working she's got like
all tattoos all over and everything like
that she's been working as an exotic
dancer and she apparently specializes in
car shows so at the beginning there's
like this big convention or whatever and
there's all these cars and there's all
these like hot women like dancing on the
cars and like doing you know so it's
obviously like
something for people that are into that
kind of thing like hot women in cars
like and want to watch them dance and
apparently she's kind of like famous in
this little subculture because there's
one extended scene of her like doing
this like really very erotic dance like
on this cadillac which has like flames
painted all over it and she has all
these people coming over and watching
they're like asking alexia alexia like
they asking for her autograph and
pictures and stuff like that and uh as
much as she seems like super into this
car
while she's dancing on it um not so much
the people she's just kind of like yeah
hi here's a selfie and like here's my
you know autograph now piss off you know
what i mean and it's like she doesn't
really talk a lot she's very very stoic
so like i said she's very very cold
emotionless and you're led to believe
that it's probably some trauma that
happened to her not the accident um so
probably something to do with her dad
not too long after this this one she's
going out like after the convention or
whatever she's going out to the parking
lot to get in her car and go home
and this dude starts like following her
and like she's like oh [ __ ] and like
starts running and he starts running and
then she gets in her car and he like
pops in the window and he's like alexia
i'm your biggest fan and i'm i think i'm
in love with you and maybe maybe we
could be friends and like you'll grow to
love me too and blah blah and she's just
kind of like looking at him like what
the [ __ ] you know what i mean like she's
like i said she doesn't talk all that
much
um and he just keeps leaning in her
window and she's like [ __ ] what am i
gonna do and then he basically like
leans in her window like kisses her like
forces himself like into her face uh at
which point
she pulls out this kind of she had like
this kind of uh stick like a chopstick
type thing which was holding her hair
back and she pulls it out and basically
like rams the [ __ ] into the dude's ear
in a pretty grisly
scene so she kills the dude uh and then
just kind of like [ __ ] leaves him
there
so because he's gotten kind of like
brain juice all over her
she goes back into the convention hall
and like into the bathrooms there like
where all the models showered and
whatnot goes in there take a shower to
like wash all the goo off and while
she's in there she hears kind of this
banging sound
at the door and she goes to the door
like completely naked she's she's naked
a lot in this uh movie by the way and so
i mean if that's your thing it's not
it's not like
it's weird because it's not really like
presented as erotic usually i mean
because it gets like pretty [ __ ] up
later on like i said this is a little
bit of a cronenbergian like body horror
type thing going on too so it's not like
meant to be super titillating but so she
goes out and she hears the door she
opens the door
and the cadillac that she was dancing on
earlier um dancing on the hood is there
like almost like it called her because
it's somebody knocked on the door and it
obviously wasn't the car so this is like
i said this is like a supernatural type
it's you know so it turns on its lights
and it's like flashing and she goes to
it
and gets in there's nobody in there and
she gets in and essentially like has sex
with the car um you know the car is like
jumping up and down and stuff like that
it's like it's funny but it's also kind
of like
i don't know it's also kind of like
disturbing a little bit so there's that
now uh we find out later like not too
long after this
that alexia's um having sex with the car
has resulted in a pregnancy
now
uh interestingly the pregnancy you're
kind of like the whole throughout the
whole movie you're kind of like what the
hell is going to come out of the of her
womb because
her like her nipples and vagina and
stuff like that like start dripping like
what appears to be motor oil
so you know that it's probably going to
go in like some weird kind of like
machine like human machine hybrid type
of direction now she does try to abort
like by sticking that same stick that
she's stuck in that dude's ear like she
tries to like ram it up and just but it
doesn't really take so there's that as
it goes on we find out that this guy
that she killed in the parking lot
is probably not alexia's uh first victim
and you determine that probably in fact
she is likely a serial killer
and this is kind of like uh reinforced
later on like pretty much the first it's
this movie's kind of divided into two
halves it's not super obvious but the
first half is kind of like her doing her
like serial killer type thing where you
know she killed that guy and
at first you're kind of led to believe
oh maybe that was just like self-defense
because he was like trying to push his
way like force his way onto her and like
she killed him for that but then later
on she kind of seems like she's starting
to or she wants like some kind of human
connection like so she does try to
you know have sex with you know women
and men and she's trying to like make
some kind of like connection in that way
but it never seems to work out because
she doesn't really she seems almost kind
of like soulless like everything has
just been
stripped out of her like through trauma
like i said she's very very cold she's
very emotionless but then she still has
kind of like this kind of barely
concealed rage like underneath the
surface so there's that too
so basically this one girl that she's
kind of been dating and stuff like that
they're kind of like back at her house
and
she just decides like after kind of like
making out with her and stuff like that
she's like i'd you know i'm just going
to kill her so she just like [ __ ]
starts stabbing her and [ __ ] like that
and then it turns out that there's all
these other people in the house like all
this girl's other roommates that alexia
didn't know about and she's like well
[ __ ] so now she has to kill like all
these other people
now during this big
spree that she's going on like all these
people in this house one of the girls
that you know she tries to kill gets
away and reports her to the police now
alexia it should be noted still lives
with her parents
and as i mentioned earlier they're very
distant like there's this one really
interesting scene where she's kind of
like up and she's like making breakfast
and her dad is like making himself
breakfast like presumably before he goes
to work i think he's a doctor or
something like that
and they're just like passing by each
other and just like not even looking at
each other not even speaking to one
another or anything like that her mom
seems a little bit more
warm but not really so like it seems
like there's this huge disconnect like
in the family which i said is implied
that it has something to do with like
some past trauma or some past uh you
know sexual abuse or something like that
which is not spoken about in the family
that's kind of the way i took it anyway
what ends up happening after this uh the
one girl like gets escapes like after
this murder spree that alexia did
which she didn't really i mean you know
i'm not excusing it obviously she did
kill that one girl just like in cold
blood they were just laying there going
oh nice and then she's just like i just
want to stab this [ __ ] bam and then she
just does that because like i said she
kind of feels like
i don't know i guess she doesn't see any
reason not to like i said she almost
seems like and that's where i kind of
think the whole thing about like
titanium like the titanium plate in her
head and then like the more metal that
comes later on uh is just her feeling
like she's just like a machine like she
doesn't have a soul or she doesn't have
any humanity or anything like that
so after this where this girl escapes
and goes to the cops
obviously um alexia is kind of like
forced to go on the run at this point
because uh the girl that escaped like
got a pretty damn good look at her face
and now there's this kind of like um a
police sketch of alexia that looks
pretty much exactly like her like all
over the media
so uh alexia basically she ends up at
this bus station she sees her face all
over the police sketches she's like holy
[ __ ] she sees this other police poster
that gives her
an idea
uh albeit a very dastardly one
so a long time like ten years prior to
the events of the movie there was a
seven-year-old boy named adrian legrand
who disappeared and hasn't been found
since
and they've done like an age progression
the weird thing is i'm not entirely sure
i thought it was implied
that alexia had maybe killed him or so
like 10 years ago because she was kind
of [ __ ] up when she was a kid too but
i don't know maybe i'm just like jumping
to conclusions on that because they do
kind of have a lot of
things about like missing kids and like
missing like for the past 10 years so
you're kind of maybe and like i said
maybe i'm reading too much into it but
it does seem like maybe she's been doing
the serial killer thing like for a long
time even when she was like a little kid
but i don't know if that's if i'm taking
it a step too far
but so this kid disappeared 10 years ago
he was 7 years old named adrian legrand
and in the bus station the same one
where the police sketches of her face
are she sees age progression uh photos
of adrian legrand what he would look
like nowadays and it so happens that
what he would look like nowadays kind of
kind of looks like her a little bit and
she's kind of like well maybe i can kind
of you know change my appearance a
little bit to look more like that so she
goes into the bus station bathroom she
cuts off a lot of her hair she like she
dyes it and she shaves off her eyebrows
and she busts her nose which is a really
unpleasant scene to watch like on the
side of the sink like she busts around
so she can kind of like reshape it so
she doesn't look like herself anymore
and then she goes to the cops and says
i'm adrienne legrand uh you know all
grown up and she's just kind of like not
gonna tell them what happened but she's
just gonna say here i am i reappeared
now at this point this is probably like
i don't know if it's like the halfway
point of the movie but this is where the
the movie goes kind of like i don't want
to say it goes in a different direction
because it doesn't really but it kind of
just goes into this other like storyline
so she gets picked up by adrian's dad
who is a firefighter named vincent
and
pretty much from the outset i mean the
police ask him like look do you want a
dna test like to make sure that this is
really your son
and vincent seems to get offended it's
like do you think i wouldn't recognize
him
um so he looks at alexia who is
pretending to be adrian
he says yes that's him
but you're pretty sure from the
beginning that vincent is
sure that this is not his son but he is
so distraught
uh that his son was taken 10 years ago
and was never found and he never figured
out what happened to him that it's
almost kind of like he's willing to
allow himself to
indulge in the fantasy that this is his
son and he doesn't really care who it is
and like he does actually kind of say
that outright later on he's like you're
still my son i don't care who you are uh
so there's that
now vincent kind of has his own [ __ ]
going on where because one of the themes
of this movie too is kind of like the
way
that your body
your like your physical body can like
betray you whether it's through aging
which you see through like vincent
because he's kind of like an older guy
he's a firefighter and he works out and
he's real bulk and everything like that
but you can see that he's just kind of
like shooting up steroids like nobody's
[ __ ] business and he's trying to do
all these pull-ups and he can't do it
anymore he's getting really ragey and
like upset about it so his body is
betraying him and in the same way
alexia's body who's pregnant remember so
honestly like when she goes to like pass
herself off as a boy she has to pretty
much like tape down like constantly tape
down her her breasts and her belly so
they don't know that she's a woman like
a pregnant woman so as it goes on and
she gets more and more pregnant it's
gonna become more and more obvious that
she's not adrien that she's not a boy um
you know you're kind of like wondering
is vincent gonna figure out and the
thing about it too is that vincent who's
kind of like the father father figure of
all these other firefighters who are all
these big bulky like buff men
and they kind of feel like that vincent
is being taken for a ride because they
pretty much know that that's not his son
and they know that he's just like
indulging in some but like i said
vincent seems aware of it too
even though he just like doesn't want to
talk about it because he's so
traumatized by his son you know probably
being dead or being kidnapped that he's
willing to just play into the illusion
just to have a you know his son back in
his life even if it's not really his son
so as i said i don't want to spoil too
much more about it than that but like i
said
it gets like pretty
grody because you know as alexia's
pregnancy like progresses you can see
like her her boobs like i said like
start leaking like motor oil and you can
see like her skin like starts to split a
little bit and it looks like there's
like shiny like titanium like underneath
her belly so you kind of know that
something is like really bad is going to
happen but then the whole thing about
her relationship her burgeoning
relationship between
her and vincent is like this really
really bizarre
because it's kind of like you're kind of
led to believe that
her family that she came from like there
was no love in it and it was just like i
said there's an implication that maybe
her dad like did some sexual abuse
toward her and so she has this sort of
like ambivalence about family but as her
and victor kind of like
establish a rapport with one another
she almost
seems like i don't know they get like
this really really strange like
relationship going but they almost seem
to like
she almost seems to like find some love
when she's pretending to be someone else
you know what i mean because she's like
pretending to be this this guy's
kid so
it's really really weird like it's just
this really strange like psychological
like family drama type thing that
happens and it's just like there's some
really [ __ ] up [ __ ]
so it's not going to be for everybody um
because it's kind of like i said it's
kind of grotesque and it's kind of uh
really strange
but i mean thematically i thought it was
like pretty brilliant
the way it kind of explores
trauma the way trauma can turn you uh
you know just kind of make you
emotionless because it seems like alexia
after whatever trauma she suffered which
like i said isn't
isn't like stated outright but is more
like implied that she just kind of like
shut down like all her mushrooms shut
down
and she just became
a machine like i said so like the inside
of her body turning to titanium is kind
of like a a metaphor for that um it's
also kind of talks a lot about
gender identity uh things like that
because you know her pretending to be a
boy and then there's this whole thing
about vincent maybe he's gay and like
all the other um firefighters like
there's all kind of like weird sexual
tension going on there um as i said sort
of like loss of control over one's own
body whether it's through aging or
pregnancy or whatever it is
and also kind of like a strange message
about maybe
finding love and acceptance where you
least expect it like finding family
among strangers um even if you have to
kind of like take on another identity to
do it so there's a lot of really rich
like symbolism and a lot of really rich
like metaphors going on in this movie
which i think is probably the reason
that
so many critics responded to it um this
is definitely one i need to watch again
because
there's a lot going on kind of like
underneath the surface of this like
there's a lot of subtext and you can
pick a lot of it up the first time but i
kind of feel like this is definitely one
that will reward like more watches it'll
be like a lot richer experience but as i
said if you're into like cronenbergian
type of stuff then you should probably
be really into this it's very like it
has like a weird psychosexual and i you
know i hate saying because it's it's its
own thing it's not exactly like a david
cronenberg movie but it explores some of
the same themes so if you like
cronenberg stuff then you'll probably
kind of be receptive to this as well
like i said it's not for everyone
because it is rather grotesque
and it's not really meant to be taken
absolutely literally but i thought it
was fantastic and i'm really kind of
curious to see if any of you guys have
seen it and what you thought about it as
i said it's on hulu uh if you have hulu
you can watch it on there for free i'm
not really sure where else it's
streaming but i'm sure it's streaming
somewhere else you know elsewhere so let
me know if you've seen it what you
thought about it or if it sounds
interesting to you and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye